welcome back to the tutorial
on games in the first part of this
tutorial
we have seen several applications of
games on graphs
in automata theory and in logic
verification
and synthesis and we have highlighted
the importance of
parity games uh positional determinacy
of parity games which plays a crucial
role in
certain difficult automata theoretic
constructions
and we have highlighted the importance
of uh
developing efficient algorithms for
solving parity games so in this section
we are going to
take a look at closer look at the
structure of parity games
including concepts uh such as attractor
decompositions
which underpin and
proof of positional determinacy of
parity games due to
mach naughton uh and jalanka uh
and we are going to develop uh that
results uh in uh in detail
here uh see how attractor decompositions
uh and their structure emerge from
that uh algorithm uh which can be also
seen as a proof of determinancy
and we take we'll take a look at a few
variants of
magnus and jalonka algorithm that have
historically
allowed to achieve uh the best uh
running times uh for solving parity
games and
that may still be useful in the future
in order to uncover the basic structure
of a winning set or winning strategies
in parity games
which is the attractor decomposition
let's recall
the concept of a strategy graph
of a positional strategy in a parity
game
so positional strategies as we recall
are strategies that can be
determined uniquely described by a set
of edges that go out
of vertices that are owned by the
respective player either
even or odd
and in fact the positional determinancy
uh
theorem for parity games can be uh
stated in the following format
that for every parity game there are
these sets of edges
one per every vertex of the respective
player as well as a partition of the set
of vertices
into the so-called winning set for even
and
the winning set for odd
such that every cycle
in the graph of strategy sigma
inside the subgraph or in the subgraph
induced
by the set of vertices and w
even is even in the sense that the
highest priority on that cycle is even
and likewise every cycle in the
graph of strategy tall is
odd namely the highest priority
on that cycle is is odd so here we have
a very basic example
of a parity game with six vertices
partition of this set of vertices into w
even
and w odd and
strategies for player even and odd
respectively
so these are the fattest edges the three
here
in odd because there are three odd
vertices
in w odd and two fat edges
in the set w even because we have two
vertices
of even there and note that
every cycle in the strategy subgraphs
of these two strategies uh namely
the graphs which consist of those fat
edges as well as all outgoing edges of
the opponent
in their respective sets um all
cycles in uh these graphs
are um winning for their respective
player
so now i would like to argue that
once we take a graph in which
every cycle is even this is an example
of a graph we've already seen
previously we can extract from it
a tree-like structure uh
that structure in fact is going to to to
take the form of an ordered tree and the
order here
ordered here is is quite important and
uh
we will call this structure the
attractor decomposition or
n rather attractor decomposition
of such a graph with only even
cycles so how how are we going to to do
that
so here is is is one way to define
define
n attractor decomposition
so here's the construction uh imagine
that we have
an um a graph in which every vertex has
a priority and
for concreteness let's assume that the
top priority
in that graph is six there are no
vertices with priorities
higher than six so let's now let's
define set d
to be the set of vertices whose priority
is exactly s
now then we proceed to define set t
0 which you should think of as a
transient set
and or we will also call it
the attractor to d
so it's the set of all uh vertices
from which every path ends up in d
so there's no way to follow a path from
t 0
and avoid eventually reaching d so
that's how we define
set t 0 and i will
write this double arrow to denote that
from all vertices in this set it is
inevitable
by following any path to eventually
hit the target of that arrow which is
set d
so once we have done that we are going
to define
set r1 in this case very special way so
that that that will give us one specific
attractor decomposition but as we are
going to argue later
uh there this condition
this requirement can be can be relaxed
and we will get other attractor
decompositions and that's
often a useful attractive
thing to do so we will define set r1 in
this case
as the set of all vertices
in the subgraph obtained after removing
these two top sets d
and t 0
from which vertex of priority 5
cannot be reached so from r1 no path
reaches 5. now this set must be
non-empty
if this set
of vertices which is obtained by
removing d
and t 0 is not empty why is that well
because if if from
every vertex in this
sub graph we can reach a vertex of
priority 5
then necessarily there will be
a path on which 5 occurs infinitely many
times or there will be a cycle
there will be a cycle in which the
highest priority is 5 because note there
are no vertices of priority 6 anymore
because they were
all in the top slice d but that would
contradict our assumption that
we started from a graph with only even
cycles
so so let's set r1 must be no empty okay
note that
because vertex 5 vertex of priority 5
cannot be
reached it is necessarily the case that
all priorities in the set r1
are at most 4. observe
also that while there may be
some edges from vertices in r1
that go either to t0
or to d it
is impossible for any edge to go from
r1 to the rest of the graph that we
haven't considered
so far why is that
well because if there was an
edge from r1
to outside of r1 then
because all vertices outside of r1 have
a path
to reach a 5 so would the vertex from
which that edge originated
now let's in turn define set
t1 to be the set of vertices
from which all paths
inevitably reach the union of d
t 0 and r 1.
now note that in this set there can be
vertices
of priorities up to 5. one way to call
this set is that it's a transient set
because
all paths eventually leave it another
would be to say that this set is
the attractor two sets to the unions of
union of sets d d0 and r1 and
indeed this is the reason why we are
talking about
attractors here
we can carry on with this construction
in the remaining set
unless it is empty we can again define
set r2 like we defined set r1
by saying that this is the set of
vertices from which
within that remaining subgraph
no path reaches vertex of priority five
this subgraph may contain cycles
but note that it cannot have any vertex
of priority five and
moreover uh there is no uh edge that
goes out of this uh set into the
previous that
until uh now unexplored part of the
graph
we can then define t2 in an analogous
way which is that
e attractor to of to the union of d
t 0 r 1 t 1 and r
2 and continue this construction until
we exhaust the set of all vertices
in the graph now note that in this
construction
we haven't explored
the remaining substructure of sets r1 r2
and so on
and indeed those are again even graphs
because
if the original graph was even then all
the cycles in those subgraphs are
are even as well but the sub graphs
now have significantly well have
priorities that are at
least two smaller than the highest
priority
in the original graph so in subgraphs r1
r2 and so on all the priorities are
bounded
by four so now we can apply this
definition of decomposing a graph in
this manner
inductively to those uh to those
sub-graphs and uh that's how
we obtain an attractor decomposition so
an attractor decomposition
is an a recursive structure um
in which some of the sets namely the
green ones
uh get their own decompositions
now note that the order in which we have
applied
these operations of um
of collecting all the sets
all the vertices from which all paths
reach to what we have explored so far
or all the vertices from which no vertex
of priority 5 is
is can be reached the order matters
and we are going to reflect that by
denoting this
recursive structure of a decomposition
of the attractor decomposition by
drawing suitable ordered trees so
in this tree here which reflects the
structure of this
attractor decomposition the order
matters the children of the root which
is labeled by
set d uh
uh is from left to right now the first
child is labeled
by set d0 so it's the attractor that
transients it
and the second child of the root is
labeled
by well that will
be determined by the attractor
decomposition
of the subgraph r1 itself so here we
have
a whole tree hanging down
from that from that node that reflects
the
attractor decomposition of set r1 third
child is labeled by the
transient set t1 the fourth child is
labeled by
again the attractor decomposition of
subgraph r2 and so on
now in order to reflect uh
the highest possible priorities in each
of those
subgraphs we are going to define uh
so-called levels in that tree every node
in
in the tree is going to have its level
uh and in particular set d will be on
level
six then all the red uh
sets all the transient sets uh will be
on level five
then the roots of uh the
trees describing the shape of attractor
decompositions of r1 r2 and so on will
be on level four
and so on and so forth
now that construction worked if we
made the assumption that the original
graph
was even namely every cycle had the
property that the highest
priority on it was even
what i would like to argue is that it is
not difficult
to establish that
existence of such a decomposition
is in fact equivalent to the property
that a graph um uh
in in a graph all cycles
are even so what we have shown was that
if
a graph is even then it has an
attractive decomposition because always
we can find the non-empty set r1 from
which which allows us to continue with
the
with the construction and in this way uh
extend that construction to the whole
graph
uh exhaust all vertices in it but it is
also
not too difficult to show that if there
is an attractor decomposition
of a graph then uh all cycles in it
are even and the reason for it is uh
hidden in those gray arrows that we've
been drawing
while describing the construction right
so the intuition here is
something we've already seen earlier
that
we cannot move to the right
through vertices of very high or
priority
uh instead we can either stay in some of
those
uh green areas which have their
attractor decompositions themselves and
hands have only even cycles
from the inductive hypothesis or
continue moving to the left
or eventually up
and when we do move up then we hit
vertices of extremely high even priority
and hence that prevents that mechanism
prevents us
from closing old cycles
now let me finally highlight
that if we from such a decomposition
remove
all nodes which
[Music]
which correspond to empty sets note that
it's only the
red nodes that can sometimes correspond
to
two empty sets then
the tree of a decomposition has the
number of leaves
that is at most the number of vertices
in the graph
moreover the height of that tree is
really dictated
by the highest possible priority
so if d is the the number of distinct
priorities in the graph
then then such a decomposition
will have height roughly d half
so now that we have
seen the concepts of an attractor
decomposition
for graphs that contain only even cycles
uh we have perhaps enough understanding
of what
makes winning strategies and parity
games of positional strategies and
parity games winning for player even
to uh develop a proof
of positional uh determinacy
for parity games and that proof takes
the form of
uh of an algorithm that has been
proposed originally for
more general case of mother games by
mcnaughton
but also then instantiated to the
special case of party games
and presented in a popular way
by jalonka and that's the algorithm we
are going to
now discuss together with
its uh embedded proof of positional
determinancy of parity games
so let's now generalize the concept of
an
attractor from graphs to games
given some target set let's call it
capital d
we'll say that the attractor
to that set four player even
here we denote player even by square
is going to be the set of vertices
that are winning for uh
square in a reachability game
on the graph where the target
set to be reached infinite number of
steps
is the target set d and this
set can be quite easily computed and now
i will show you how and in fact
this is the backwards induction
technique for
solving finite games so
we are going to compute the attractor
for even to the target set d
step by step and in every step we are
going to include
exactly all those vertices from which
square can
force a move into d
in one step
so the first layer consists of all the
square vertices
from which there is at least one edge
and that will be the strategy for square
one edge to move straight into d
it will also contain all the triangle
vertices where triangle is the opponent
of square
from which all outgoing edges enter d
so i hope you will you would agree that
these are exactly all the vertices
either squares
or triangles from which square has a
strategy
and it is indeed a positional strategy
uh
because it's just one of the outgoing
edges from all squares
to reach d in at most
in exactly in fact one step now if we
repeat this construction and construct
l2
the layer 2 to consist of all those
vertices
from which square
has an edge into l1
and all outgoing edges
of triangle
go either into l1 or d
then we will have now collected the set
of vertices
from which square has a strategy to
reach d in at most two steps now by
repeating this construction
until no more vertices can be included
using one of such
rules we exactly
obtain the set of vertices from which
square has a strategy
to infinite number of steps
reach vertex and d and we can prove that
this is indeed
all such vertices because we can
[Music]
then argue that
in all vertices that have not been
included in any of the layers
uh the opponent triangle
has a strategy to stay in that remaining
set forever
all right so that's why we call this set
a trap
for square because square can't escape
from there
and hence a square can never reach d
right and that's that's straightforward
straightforward implication of the rules
that we used in order to construct the
layers because
if we cannot include a triangle in any
of
the layers that means that it has at
least one edge
that doesn't go into any of the layers
we have defined so far
and if we cannot include a square
that means that it does not have an edge
going into one of the layers computed so
far
right so what you can interpret
this construction as is a determinancy
proof
for a two-player game on graphs in which
one player
has the reachability objective which is
to
on the path infinite number of steps hit
set d and the other player has the
complementary objective which is often
referred to as a safety objective
of avoiding this target set d
indefinitely so right the conclusion of
this
very simple argument is that
um reachability games and
safety games are positionally determined
right because
uh the reachability player square in our
case
has a positional strategy consisting of
those edges that
move us closer to d in every step and
likewise a triangle
on the rest of the game graph
has again a positional strategy which is
just any edge
that does not cross the boundary into
the attractor
from now on uh when referring to
winning strategies in reachability games
as described here
the positional winning strategies and
reachability games
we will refer to them as attractor
strategies
we are now ready to prove
positional determinancy of parity games
and
the proof we are going to present uh can
be also seen
as as an algorithm and it's a recursive
algorithm
that was proposed by mcnaughton and
popularized
by jalanka what we are going to show
is that remarkably positional
winning strategies in parity games not
only always exist
but they have this very special simple
form
where we can explicitly describe them as
a union over
partition of the set of vertices
of a collection of reachability
strategies
to various target sets
so how does the inductive
proof of positional determinacy
which is embedded in the mcnauton
geelonk algorithm work
well there are three cases in it and two
are quite easy the first one is
literally trivial
so the first case is the following
let d capital d
like we as we've discussed before
be the set of vertices whose
priority is the highest
priority used in the whole game graph
now without loss of generality we can
assume that the top priority
is an even number if it is odd then
all we are going to say can be done
by swapping the roles of the two players
so the first case case a
is when it so happens that the
attractor for box which is even
to that set capital d of
the highest even set of vertices of
highest even priority
is in fact uh the set of all vertices
so in other words if from every
from every vertex in the game
we can in zero or more steps uh
reach a vertex in d
if it is the case then um
here is a positional winning strategy
for even
from every vertex in the game graph just
take
a disjoint union of the attractor
strategy tool
on the set of vertices that are not
in d and an arbitrary really really
arbitrary
uh positional strategy delta
on vertices on set d
so now if even uses
this disjoint union the strategy which
is the disjoint union of those two
positional strategies
what's going to happen is that
the set capital d is going to be reached
infinitely many times but
instead of but said d has
is the set of vertices of the highest
priority
which is even and hence necessarily
the highest priority seen infinitely
many times
is um is a d and hence
that is every every such play is going
to be winning for even
so this is indeed a positional winning
strategy for even so nothing really
nothing really interesting happened here
but that case is covered
so now let's assume that
the attractor to this set d
is not everything so there are some
vertices
and we are going to denote the set of
such vertices so the subgraph induced by
the set of such vertices
as g prime so the blue g prime
is an area which is not in the attractor
for even
to set capital d
now by the inductive hypothesis now we
are using induction
on the number of vertices in the game
graph
right we assume that d was not empty and
hence its attractor is not empty
therefore
g prime has fewer
vertices than the original graph by
inductive hypothesis
this game g prime has
positional winning strategies for each
of the two players so case
b is when it so happens
that the winning set for triangle or
winning set for odd in game g prime
which we denote by
w triangle prime happens to be empty
so by the inductive hypothesis uh
in this set on the subgraph g prime
player even has a positional winning
strategy
let's call it omega square prime
now i'd like to argue and it's again a
simple argument
that if we take strategy delta
strategy tool and strategy
omega box omega square prime
where strategy tall is the attractor
strategy
2d for even for b for square
and delta is an arbitrary positional
strategy on d
that strategy again
is a positional winning strategy in the
whole game
now why is that well um you know either
if we consider a play which is
consistent with that strategy it follows
that strategy
either eventually it uh stays forever
in g prime and then it is winning
because
strategy the positional strategy omega
square prime was winning
for even or infinitely many times
we visit the attractor
to d but then again using the argument
like
like before we see we had d infinitely
many times
and win in this way
so we are now ready to consider the
third and arguably the most interesting
case of that um argument behind the mach
not on genomic algorithm
like in the previous two cases we
consider
the top attractor so the attractor for
even to the set of vertices of the top
priority which we assumed with that loss
of generality to be
to be an even number and now we are
considering a subgame
g prime which is the complement of the
attractor
now in case b we assume that
player even one
everywhere in that sub game g prime now
imagine
that by the inductive hypothesis player
odd has a positional winning strategy
on some non-empty uh
set of vertices in game g prime
now that by inductive hypothesis that
does obviously means that
on the complement of that set player
even has a
positional winning strategy in that game
but let's ignore that strategy and
perhaps it's useful to to remember that
if we interpret when we interpret this
procedure
as as a recursive algorithm in a way
the work done to discover and
compute this positional winning strategy
on that sub game is thrown away
by the magnoton genolic algorithm
because the argument from now on
proceeds only by using
that winning set for odd ng prime
and the associated positional uh winning
strategy that
so let's uh let omega triangle
prime be um
a positional winning strategy on the
winning set
for for odd for player triangle
uh in game g prime
now what the magnet angelonk algorithm
does next is to compute
the attractor but now not for even but
for odd
into this light blue set
w triangle prime let's call this
attractor strategy
top prime and let this
uh be the uh the set of vertices
from which triangle or odd can reach
this
light blue set now the first argument i
would like to
now articulate is that
the strategy which is a combination of
omega triangle prime
and the attractor strategy strategy toll
prime
is a positional winning strategy for odd
on that red attractor
that means that in this part
of the game graph odd has a winning
strategy
in the whole game not in a subgame but
in the whole game
okay so that leaves us with
the rest of the game graph which we call
g double prime and
about g double prime we don't know much
yes we know that on some part of it even
use
even has a winning strategy if we just
tricked ourselves
only to the light blue area
of sub game g prime but
information about how that strategy
looks like and how it can be played is
now completely discarded lost
forgotten because what the mach nut
angelonka
the recursive magnonglock algorithm will
now do
is to make a recursive call to solve the
remaining
subgame g double prime the green area
so once that is done
second part of case c
concludes now so after that second
recursive call is made
we will have a solution of the whole
game we will have a partition
of the set of vertices into two subsets
these are the two subsets
on which respectively even and odd
have positional winning strategies so
the winning set
for triangle or for odd will consist not
only
of that light blue set and its
attractor that we have discussed on the
previous slide
but it will also include
the winning set for triangle for odd
in this remaining game g double prime
while the winning set for
even in the whole game g will simply be
the winning set for even in the green
sub game g double prime and
it's not very difficult to establish
that
this is indeed correct that the
combination of these
three positional strategies guarantees a
win for
uh odd and that this
positional strategy guarantees a win for
even not in the sub games in which
they were not only in the sub games in
which they were
uh computed but also in the whole game
right so in order to to
complete that argument we have to make
sure for example that
uh from this green set it is impossible
for player odd or triangle
to escape somewhere to the left okay and
that that is guaranteed for example by
the fact that we have computed an
attractor here another attractor
hence there are no triangle edges going
into that
attractor uh but also by the property
of winning sets in the parity game right
so there cannot be
a vertex in the winning set um
in this green sub game g double prime
the winning set for even from which odd
can escape to
its own winning set in that sub game g
double prime so
in other words there are no escapes for
odd
from this set to the left and likewise
there are no escapes for even from these
three sets
to the right and hence the winning
strategies that worked
in the subgames also work in the whole
game so that completes
the proof of positional determinacy
of parity games at least for finite
graphs
that also can be understood as a
recursive
algorithm for solving party games where
you can think of the algorithm as
performing either uh
no recursive goals that's case a
and after computing one attractor the
game is completely solved so that's
that's from the algorithmic point of
view that's a very
easy case where the algorithm makes one
recursive call
and after that immediately terminates
with a with answer
that's case b or
it makes two recursive calls uh one on
game g prime obtaining uh a winning set
for
triangle which is not ever all of the
game g prime
and then second time on game g
double prime
now if you think about carefully about
uh how all these strategies that
uh the makhnot angelonka algorithm
uses to construct a positional winning
strategy
for both player even and for player odd
on their winning sets
then you will realize that
they have a structure which is very
similar to the attractor decompositions
that we have discussed earlier for
even graphs of course that's the case
for
the winning set for even the case for
the winning set of player odd will be
analogous by replacing
by swapping the roles of even a odd both
in terms of
even and odd numbers uh like priorities
and
and names of players
the only difference is that the concept
of an attractor
is no different whereas before for
graphs
an attractor was the set from which all
paths
end in a target set here the concept of
an attractor
is that one of the players
in the case of the winning set for
player even uh
its player even uh has a positional
strategy
in a reachability game with a suitable
uh with a suitable target set
but otherwise uh the definition
of uh this structure
with that we call an attractor
decomposition uh is
is quite analogous perhaps the slight
difference
is in how we define sets r1
so whereas for
even graphs we had a very specific very
particular way of identifying those set
sets are the recurrent sets
here we in fact just require that they
are a trap for odd
so they have this property that odd
cannot escape from them
to the right in the diagrams that we
that we draw
but we also require that they themselves
have
an attractor decomposition right so here
we have this basic structure
of the top level of an attractor
decomposition where
we only consider the highest priority
and then you use
in this example priority 6 and then
attractor decompositions of subgames
in which the highest priority is at most
form now note that
um the attractor decomposition
of player even and that for player odd
differs slightly and this slight
asymmetry
results uh is is a consequence of the
fact that
um if the highest priority is six then
then there's no priority seven which
could play a role
of the top attractor in the winning set
for player odd okay so that's that's the
only reason
why the pictures on the left and on the
right look slightly
uh different but uh let's
highlight this subtle difference how uh
and how these
sets uh look like um by
drawing their corresponding trees like
we did for
uh for attractor decompositions of uh of
graphs
uh and what we note here is
that the tree for odd in this case if
the highest priority as we
typically assume is even has a root
at the level which is which doesn't
correspond to any vertices
and hence its label is is the empty set
now let's complete the analysis of the
magneton gelonka algorithm and its
underlying proof of positional
determinacy by
estimating or analyzing the running time
that this recursive algorithm requires
in the worst case um on finite graphs
but
before we talk about finite graphs
and complexity of algorithms let's just
uh
quickly uh mention uh what
and how this algorith how this argument
might work for infinite graphs recall
that
one of the first motivations we've
mentioned for the need to establish
positional determinacy of parity games
was
complementation of tree automata and in
that application
the games on that on which we need
to get um positional determinacy
are in fact inherently uh infinite uh
because
uh because they are played on an
infinite tree or
some structure that is based on an
infinite tree
so it is essential to be able to prove
positional determinancy
not only for finite graphs but also for
infinite graphs so it turns out that uh
this
argument of magneton and gelonka
can be extended to infinite graphs where
instead of
uh using induction you use transfinite
or ordinal
induction and what happens there is that
instead of having this view that
we make up to two recursive calls
maybe a more natural way to to look at
it is that we start with a game with
some number of priorities
and then we the second recursive call
can be seen as a continuation of an
iterative process
in which we repeatedly solve uh
smaller and smaller games with one
fewer priorities okay so whenever we are
at iteration i
and work on game gi we make the
first recursive call on game gi
prime and then
the second so in this
only interesting case uh c uh we shave
off some attractor uh of
a winning set in the sub game and then
we obtain the next game which is simply
the next
the next game in the sequence so to say
so in a finite graph of course the
number of such iterations
is going to be bounded in the worst case
by the number of vertices because in
every iteration
we remove at least one vertex from the
from the game graph
therefore if we view
this recursive algorithm as having a top
level in which such an iteration is
performed
in which uh every iteration solves a
game
with one or more fewer priorities uh
then uh we can view the tree of
recursive calls
of the algorithm as having the original
game g in the root
and then all these games g i prime
as as children of the root
now since it's a tree of degree
bounded by n and of height at most d
minus one
uh it follows that uh the number of
nodes in it and hence the number of
recursive calls
of the magnoline algorithm in the worst
case is
is uh bounded by n power d minus one so
it's
exponential in the number of priorities
and unfortunately there are examples
which show that
this worst case can indeed be attained
so so there are examples of uh parity
games for
on which the magnot and zhilongka
algorithm requires two power
omega of n recursive calls
or on which
the algorithm requires and divided by d
power d minus one um uh recursive calls
now one um quick corollary of
positional determinacy of parity games
uh which was pointed out
by emerson jatla and sisla back in the
1990s
is that deciding the winner in parity
games
is in np and the reason is simple
namely if positional
winning strategies always exist all you
need to do
is to guess a positional strategy that
is winning
if one exists and then verify that it is
indeed
a winning strategy how can can this be
done well we
recall this simply boils down to taking
the strategy sub graph
and verifying that every cycle in a
strategy subgraph
is is even obviously the number of
cycles may be exponential but there is a
simple polynomial time
algorithm which allows to to verify that
and that gives an
np procedure now the problem
intriguingly is also in
in coin p because by determinacy
if one player doesn't have a positional
winning strategy then
the other one does so verifying that
a player does not have a winning
strategy both down to verifying that the
opponent has a winning strategy
and hence membership in
in coinp so that that makes uh
the problem of of uh deciding the winner
in parity games
uh um well characterized
uh and there are very few uh well
characterized
problems over the years that have
survived not having
a polynomial time algorithm eventually
you know famous examples include
linear programming and and primality
so so that that suggests that solving
parity games should not be too difficult
finally i'd like to discuss um several
variants
of the magnot angelonka algorithm so
before i do so
let me introduce two uh very natural and
very basic
concepts uh so so one of them is called
the dominion and that's a natural
[Music]
winning subset uh for a player so it's a
set of vertices in a game
uh so the minion for for square is a set
of vertices
this one u uh on which
player square has a strategy that
is winning for her
while the opponent can never escape that
set
so you know dominion is a golden
standard if every dominion is a subset
of the winning set um in a game so so
finding dominia is
is uh is very useful because once you
have identified a dominion you can just
shave it off and then
you are left with solving a smaller game
now the other concept
is instead of a snare and as you can see
a snare is simply a relaxation of of the
dominion condition
so a snare is a
set of the disease on which
player in this case square so it's a
snare for triangle so it's like a bed
area for triangle
uh so the opponent the square has a
strategy
which as long as a play
stays within set u is winning for
for player square now triangle can
escape
from a snare there may be some edges
that go out of the snare
but if those opportunities for escape
are not used then triangle will lose so
a snare for triangle is really
a bad area of a triangle from which
however
in contrast to a dominion a triangle
may be able to escape so if we identify
a snare what we have learned
is that we know that triangle will have
an incentive to
to leave that uh leave that set
so note that if we look at this
fundamental concept of an attractor
decomposition
then all these recurrent sets both for
in an attractor decomposition for even
and an attractor decomposition for odd
are snares for the opponent
because in them
players have winning strategies
now the opponents may
be allowed to escape from them but keep
in mind recall
that the opponent can only escape from
them
to the left and hence such escapes
can only happen a bounded number of
times because
before before a move up happens
uh in which case a high good priority
is hit so so snares
occur naturally in the wild in
attractor decompositions of of winning
sets
so this motivates um a generalization
of the concept of an attractor
which goes as follows consider that you
have some
set of snares let's call it a library of
snares some of those snares can be
snares for a triangle
some of them can be snares for a square
so either for odd or for even now if we
are computing
an attractor um generalization the snare
attractor
for even to uh some set target
set d and typically in mach not
angelonka style algorithms
it's always the set of vertices of the
highest current priority
and assume again that this highest
priority
is even if we are computing the
attractor for even
then the snare attractor apart from
just computing the set of vertices from
which
even or square can reach the target set
d
it also allows inclusion of
snares for the opponent so note that
they are
sets so an s this set over here
is a snare for triangle means that
as long as even is playing
inside it and triangle or square plays
inside it and the triangle doesn't
escape
then square wins
so what we allow is to include in the
snare attractor
any such snare for the opponent uh
when it is the case that all the escapes
for you for the opponent so the only
opportunities for the opponent for
triangle in this case to
uh to run away from from losing within
that snare
are in the already computed uh snare
attractor or part of the snare attractor
to
to that top priority okay so
we may at various stages of the
iteration of
computing the layers in the attractor
throw in some of the snares that we
happen to already know
uh so so this is uh used in the
following
snare attractor algorithm that was
explicitly uh
formulated by van dijk but is based on
uh ideas explored by ben rachetti del
erba and mogavero
called priority promotion which
goes as follows we try to
find more and more snares until we find
a dominion
now note that snares dominion are
special cases
of snares uh and therefore uh as soon as
we find the dominion
uh we will have made progress because uh
every dominion can be immediately shaved
off and uh
we are left with a smaller game to solve
so we start with an empty set of snares
and what this snare attractor algorithm
does
is to uh do something uh quite similar
in principle to
the magnoton gelonk algorithm but
understood not as a recursive procedure
but instead
rather as an iterative one so what does
uh magnolialonca do well
uh it makes a top recursive call
in which it shaves off the top attractor
to the highest priority so imagine that
that eight was the highest priority and
now we
shave the top attractor to
um to that to the set of vertices of the
top priority
now instead of taking a tractor we take
the snare attractor with respect to the
current set of snares that we
have already uh identified now what does
the magnolia angelonka algorithm do well
it calls itself
on a game with one fewer priority it may
be a note priority that is a top
priority now
and then of course we compute an
attractor
for the opponent for odd but
again we have a library of snares so we
allow the opponent to use snares as well
to
increase the size uh potentially
increase the size of that
that attractor so we continue doing that
until we run out of vertices
so now that if in the last attractor
the last snare attractor uh we
have this property
that a player cannot escape to an
unexplored unexplored part of the game
anymore
because uh that last attractor was was
very special they included everything
else left and that implies
that it is a snare itself
and moreover it is possible to to prove
that this snare has not been
explored found earlier so it's a new
snare that we can add
to our uh library of snares and indeed
uh uh that also implies
that this algorithm will terminate and
find a dominion because
it simply enumerates uh all the snares
until it finds
it finds a dominion
so van dijk has found examples
uh sophisticated examples on which
this algorithm which he calls snare
learning or
he calls it tangle learning uses a
different
term from that introduced by fernley
requires exponential time so this is not
this is not significantly better in
theory but it seems to work quite well
in practice
and perhaps it deserves
a better understanding another idea that
i would like to mention is that of uh
combining the basic mike not on geelong
algorithm
uh with the so-called dominion
preprocessing so this this idea is
is uh notable because um maybe
a decade ago plus it was
a technique that led to
algorithms with the best known uh
running times so recall that in the
basic
magnoton geelonk algorithm that we have
considered
there are two sub-games on which
recursive calls are made
so the idea in this variation of
magnottangelonka with dominion
pre-processing
is to try to find
to detect and delete
all dominion of certain
size before making the first recursive
call
so now let's let's uh see uh
why this may be um a sensible idea
well if we make sure
that we remove all sufficiently small
dominion
whose size is bounded by kovan
before making the first recursive call
that means
that after we have made the recursive
call
we will have removed some dominion
and because this dominion was not
discovered
in this pre-processing step this
dominion is of necessarily
is necessarily of size at least k so now
of course finding all the meaning of
size uh
at most k may be
expensive but the idea here is to trade
off
the cost of doing so with
the cost of making recursive calls of
the magnoton jalonk algorithm on large
games
so this idea has been implemented in the
following way
to improve the complexity of
solving parity games from exponential to
sub exponential by
picking this parameter k to be
roughly the square root of n where n is
the number of vertices
in the gain graph so uh this is exactly
the setting of this parameter which
balances out the cost of brute
forcing finding dominion of all dominion
of size at most k of n
uh by brute force and um
the solution of this recurrence or
rather the number of
uh or number of nodes in the tree
of uh recursive calls of a pers of a
procedure
uh uh which calls itself recursively
twice
uh first on uh
with the the size of the input n minus
one and second
the size of the input and minus square
root of n so this
peculiar uh slightly exotic uh
recurrence has this solution
and that's what led to the first
sub sub-exponential deterministic
sub-exponential algorithm
for solving parity games so here's
another application of the same
insight where there are two differences
one
is that instead of using a brute force
algorithm for finding
sufficiently small dominion a slightly
more sophisticated algorithm is
is used um in fact it's an adaptation of
of so-called progress measure algorithm
that we haven't yet discussed but we
will discuss
next week and the second difference is
that rather than
trying to find dominion of size at most
square root of n
we are aiming for finding detecting and
removing all the minia of size
at most uh cube root of n squared so
it's a bit
larger than than previously then square
root
um now it turns out that uh
and that's an idea of of shreve uh
who has uh found a clever way of
adapting this progress measure algorithm
to find all and detect all the meaning
of size at most
cube root of n squared in time which is
exponential in d but with d over 3
in the exponent and the principle here
is
again similar it's trading off the cost
of
uh finding uh right so that the choice
of this parameter is
such as to trade off the cost of uh
finding uh old dominion of certain
size with a solution of the
relevant recurrence for this adaptation
of the magnelon algorithm
so because here we are in every
iteration guaranteed to remove
at least cube root of n squared vertices
this can only happen at most cube root
times
so the number of iterations uh or
the children of the roots in the tree of
recursive causes at most
uh cube root of n uh this is the
recurrence and it turns out
shiva has shown that the the solution of
this recurrence is of the form
n power d over three plus some constant
uh so so that was um uh an algorithm
with the best
running time uh from 2007
until uh 2017
when the big breakthrough came uh in the
form of a quasi-polynomial
time algorithm uh uh um
discovered by kaluda jain who signed off
uh lee and steven
so next week we are going to uh
talk about the quasi-polynomial era in
algorithms for solving parity games